pete davidson is here to support kim
kardashian and now a source is opening
up to e.t about how the snl star is
helping his girlfriend through her
divorce from kanye west what's my life
going to look like well we know kim's
life looks a bit different since last
february when she filed for divorce from
the rapper in october she started dating
pete after making her snl hosting debut
now are you going to kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and kanye well he's made his feelings
clear you know how you gonna bring me to
snl
and kiss the dude you dating right in
front of me and everybody's like oh
that's that's cool there's also this
controversial lyric on kanye's latest
single easy
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
now a source is opening up to e.t about
how the new york native feels about it
explaining quote pete finds kanye's
lyrics and interviews about him funny
and entertaining he is super chill about
the situation and doesn't take it too
personally but he hates that kim has to
deal with the drama you just gotta roll
with it the source also adds the funny
man is supportive and reminds the mother
of four to not focus on the drama and
things seem to be going well for the new
couple the suicide squad actor publicly
called kim his girlfriend for the first
time in a recent interview with people
plus it sounds like pete is moving to
the west coast to be closer to the
skim's founder yep
yep while the 28 year old is based in
new york a source tells e.t pete is now
considering a place in los angeles and
the move makes sense because pete has
plenty of friends and work in la plus
he's quote into whatever gives him more
time with kim why not as for the beauty
mogul she's staying busy with work
gracing the march cover of vogue and
inside she gets real about what led to
her decision to divorce
telling the mag she's now prioritizing
her happiness over others she says quote
and even if that created changes and
caused my divorce i think it's important
to be honest with yourself about what
really makes you happy at the end of the
day life is about being happy
being who you are and that mentality
echoes what kim told her momager kris
jenner on the keeping up with the
kardashians finale after turning 40 this
year i realized like no i don't want
a husband that lives in a completely
different state i just want you to be
happy and joyful
and i think i haven't seen that in a
really long time
[Music]
you